did reality look different when you were
a kid of course it did the world has
changed and you have changed but I think
that only explains some of the
phenomenon I think its eeriness comes
from the incompleteness of mental time
travel our memories are not 4K movies
they're more like scripts and each time
they are performed parts of them have to
be recast
remed cobbled together from whatever
sources are available so it shouldn't be
a surprise that our memories of the Past
come to look like the recordings of of
the past available to us now not only is
mental time travel incomplete it's also
mutated over time in our memories our
perceptions get squeezed into fewer and
fewer primary categories leaving us with
a reality whose aesthetic is different
than it originally was so don't just
stop and smell the roses stop and be
here now it's the last time you will
ever be
[Music]
here